[Musique]
le ciel se voile pour la suite de notre
échappée jurassienne nous poursuivons
notre route le long du chemin de
randonnée qui traverse le département un
département réputé pour ses lacs
naturels
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a tout fait pour notre troisième
étape qui débute dans la très belle
région des lacs une beauté très fragile
que les jurassiens ont à coeur de
préserver
[Musique]
magali on est à côté d'une petit mac lui
un des quatre lacs et on est vraiment
ici dans un espace très fragile au
niveau naturel
oui effectivement en fait on est sur un
site qui est à la fois une ressource en
eau potable pour les communes du coin
mais c'est aussi en fait un écran de
diversité en fait c'est à dire qu'il ya
plein milieu naturel qui sont installés
autour des lacs
[Musique]
l'ol est très très clair c'est vraiment
limpide la pollution des gens ça peut
avoir un impact
on va avoir plusieurs impacts
potentiellement sur les milieux alors
c'est parfois directement sur les
milieux avec le piétinement par exemple
mais ça peut être aussi sur la faune et
la flore avec certaines espèces qui vont
elles dérangé par la fréquentation
magali est ce que vous avez l'intention
de réguler justement la fréquentation
voire même de limiter en fait l'accès à
ces sites là alors l'objectif c'est pas
forcément de l'imiter mais c'est mieux
organiser la fréquentation sur le site
en vraiment la canalisant sur les
sentiers pour enfin voilà pour limiter
l'impact sur sur les milieux naturels et
aussi sur la vie locale aussi pour les
habitants du village
[Musique]
on profite du retour du soleil pour vous
emmener à quelques kilomètres au lac de
nos relais et la commune de frasnoy
toute proche
une communiqué décidé il ya quelques
années de créer un camping municipal
pour limiter le camping sauvage et par
là le camping a été créée en 1974 et
donc le maire de l'époque a décidé de
sacrifier entre guillemets un champ
agricole pour pour m pour mettre les
gens donc nous dans le camping c'est de
garder le côté un peu naturel c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas vraiment
d'emplacements tout à fait voilà est-ce
que vous profitez d'être gérant de ce
camping pour sensibiliser les visiteurs
sensibiliser les touristes qui viennent
et on leur explique venant ici dès que
vous passez les limites du camping dès
que vous sortez des aides et que vous
allez sur la plage et vous êtes en
bourdiaux vélo vous êtes dans une zone
protégée une zone natura 2000
florian quand on voit l'eau comme ça on
a quand même envie de se baigner qu'est
ce que vous dites aux gens je leur dise
c'est votre responsabilité si vous allez
c'est votre responsabilité corporelle
physique si vous faites mal si vous vous
noyez et c'est aussi votre
responsabilité morale vis-à-vis de
l'environnement
pascal est le directeur du tourisme dans
le jura on le voit il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de monde cette année
est-ce qui a pas trop de monde on peut
considérer que là on est à un palier et
qu'il faudrait pas charger en fait de
sites de davantage de fréquentation on
veut développer en fait une forme de ce
lot tourisme d'écotourisme c'est-à-dire
de tourisme lié à l'environnement qui
naples qui a le plus faible impact
possible par rapport à la au site
naturel
alors on a suivi toute cette semaine et
on va suivre encore l'échappée
jurassienne est-ce que ça c'est une
forme de tourisme que vous avez à coeur
de développer
c'est une forme de tourisme de
découverte où on vient pas faire du
tourisme de masse et se concentrait tous
au même endroit on découvre le
département sur tout un linéaire on peut
accueillir une fréquentation qui serait
parti dans le temps et dans l'espace
on vient pas dans le jura par hasard on
choisit le jura comme une destination
nature donc il faut savoir la préserver
[Musique]
notre troisième étape s'achève dans la
très belle vallée de la seine demain
nous avons rendez vous aux russes je
crois que c'est passionnel mais j'ai un
petit doute mais non mais non à
quelqu'un